comment serait-il possible que vous
sachiez tous faire
face aux recteurs d'académie ce lundi 28
août de nouveaux professeurs les
lauréats du concours 2010 est cette
année une souris stagiaires c'est un
sentiment partagé je suis à la fois
stressé très heureuse de pouvoir
concrètement devenir professeur des
écoles après une année de préparation au
concours donc c'est vraiment un moment
très attendu
rassurer donner confiance aux 350
nouveaux enseignants qui intègre
l'académie la journée est rythmée par
des discours et des ateliers le concours
2017 est un excellent cru avec une
moyenne d épreuves supérieur à 14 sur
l'ensemble de quatre épreuves
extrêmement exigeante et que cette
réussite au concours est sanctionné à
l'issue de cette année de stage leur
demander d'être audacieux d'expérimenter
et on a bien vu que il en était presque
surpris mais c'est bien ainsi que nous
avancerons parce qu'il n'ya pas une
façon d'enseigner à un ensemble d'élèves
l'académie accueille près de trois cent
mille élèves cette année pour ces jeunes
professeurs le vif du sujet comment ce
lundi 4 septembre à 8h30